hello welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Jessica Clemens and now that echo's over
we're Paving the way to Daredevil born
again again acknowledging the history of
Netflix's Daredevil series and bringing
in the Defenders this will include a
much less Hawaiian sherp Punk version of
Wilson Fisk and that filthy murderous
Ruffian were used to according to
Vincent denafo now that Kingman has
maybe found the light and will be
running for May being exactly what the
civilians of New York want what does
that mean for Daredevil who is
exhaustively the opposite and the same
of Wilson fist in this video we'll
discuss some of the ways that Kingpin
and Daredevil could approach their new
roles as heroes and villains inside New
York City at the end of this video I'll
give you what I think is most likely
going to happen but first be sure to
check out nerd rot. shop to check out
the latest and greatest in new rockstars
merch you can grab a shirt featuring
Kingpin or maybe your shirt featuring
the best bubs Deadpool and Wolverine or
maybe one of our many other great
options grabbing some merch From Nerd
rot. shop is the best way to support the
channel and all the work we do here in
this video that I brought to you and me
just being here so go check it out we
learn in Echo episode 4 that Kingpin and
Maya were alive during the blip in 2021
she's also wearing the same clothes at
the dinner scene that she wears again in
an episode one flashback so assuming
those flashbacks were in chronological
order she fought Daredevil the next day
right after her final moving on from the
theoretical to the Practical as Fisk
says so Maya Kingpin and Daredevil all
didn't blip other than what I mentioned
earlier Hawkeye killed Maya's dad during
the blip though stages of grief are
super long sometimes I think Maya's dad
dying and her fighting Daredevil
happened within a short window of time
she didn't age and she wasn't the best
fighter yet yet she kept up with Hawkeye
and Ronin in episode 5 way better than
she did with Daredevil so her birth of a
villain Arc was a springboard and we see
her skills getting better throughout the
Hawkeye flashbacks also though it might
not be 2022 we're playing ly Le 47
shitty bang which technically came out
in 2022 that's a loose connection but
it's still within the blip territory it
would also make sense that they're
dropping little teases to life during
the blip in echko if our newest Defender
storyline supports Daredevil and
kingpin's next venture we know from past
set photos a little bit of Daredevil
born again also takes place during the
the blip and arguably yeah a lot of
creative restructuring is happening to
born again so they could change the
timeline of the story but I'd argue
Marvel has major bullet points when they
plan their projects out and the
creatives help them get to those
Milestones so I think the bones of being
set a little during the blip are still
there since that event appears to affect
Kingpin heavily and we still need to
know how he got out of prison if that's
true that means Kingpin and Daredevil
have been going at it during the blip
allegedly for 5 years and you can tell
in Daredevil's tone he's done with it
really listen to his opening and Echo
I've been watching them all night and
then you guys show up and screwed
everything up we've heard Matt irritated
before but this was Stone Cold beside
himself failure in his tone like he's
been awake forever and monitoring every
path to Kingpin again unsuccessfully
poor Matt's just working overtime while
the other Heroes and Vigilantes are just
off killing people hiding or not
existing bringing the universe back is
far more important than stopping a crime
Lord in New York but still deserves
attention as the ripple effect can
really up New York when everyone
returns and Matt sees that so that in
mind we're not seeing much of Vanessa so
I'm assuming she was blipped because
there is no way in hell that you are
telling me in those flashbacks and an
echo Vanessa was never introduced to
Maya that just I I I refuse to believe
it so what leverage does Daredevil
really have after the events of season 3
what support and character would he
embody if Karen and foggy were blipped
remember Daredevil works alone but
functions off those around him he
doesn't bode well in isolation unlike F
so during the blip he's probably
deteriorating while FIS thrives out of
jail no leverage on his head and a play
ground of freedom and trouble waiting to
be formed that would make me spiral too
and look Daredevil smart I get it but
he's also got a lot of issues in
Netflix's MCU we explored the violence
religious and grossly abusive tones in
Daredevil and an echo it reminds us and
emphasizes we'll get that and the
psychological torture so we must be
ready for a dark dark blip in New York
City's underground crime scene and how
that molds Daredevil and lifts Wilson
Fisk up also like I'm sorry just imagine
being Daredevil during the blip and not
being able to see what's happening but
hearing all of the heartbeats around you
just disappear and faint screams of New
York truly imagine a man whose power
depends on a sense of hearing and
hearing the world just stop opening born
again with that scene would be
horrifying but so eye opening and we'd
be in the same point of view and bubble
of confusion cuz what would you do
normally Matt listens and Springs to
action but there are too many alarms and
too many calls where do you begin
there's no foggy no Karen and Matt
didn't know what the snap was yet so
this confusion probably led to his
reluctance to act immediately because
jumping head first into the unknown
isn't going to solve why all the people
just disappeared this would be the first
tick to drive our boy mad I keep talking
about Karen and foggy as though they
blip so Karen and foggy were
instrumental in building Daredevil and
keeping him grounded in the fog of Rage
he was maneuvering they were the
sidekicks he needed fogy was the only
family he really had left other than
crazy ass stick he helped navigate
Matt's actions and guided him as a
vigilante from legal consequences while
Karen put herself in danger all the time
for the man together they were Matt's
voice of reason I believe the original
discourse of them not showing up on born
again isn't because of casting but for
the story if the two have been blipped
that voice of reason is just gone
occasionally I have to leave my house
and whenever that happens I use music as
a shield to block out the grocery store
the airport the coffee shop whatever
rayon's everyday earbuds are a critical
part of my armor against the outside
world and their noise isolation mode is
crucial the optimized gel tips on
rayon's everyday earbuds make sure
they're snug and comfortable and they
don't budge or jostle like some other
earbuds do also the touch controls make
it super easy to control what I'm
listening to without having to dig my
phone out of my pockets God I hate that
just by tapping my earbuds I can change
the volume skip a track or answer a call
super easily they also have 32-hour
battery life and can support 8 hours of
continuous play plus they're half the
price of other premium audio Brands plus
raycon offers free and easy returns free
shipping and buy now pay lader options
and I know you guys love that buy now
pay lader option cuz I abuse it raycon
products have earned tens of thousands
of five star reviews and it's not hard
to see why click the link in the
description box or go to buy raycon.com
neww rockstars to get 15% off your
raycon purchase plus free shipping m
Beyond a ton of guilt and clear
Obsession Daredevil suffers from
depression and those emotions shape our
characters values as they push forward
but these characters are going to be
challenged by their antagonist we see
this time and time again in the defender
Saga so Kingpin will use this to his
advantage and manipulate and
successfully orchestrate the downfall of
Daredevil and Born Again by using his
weaknesses the city his support system
and his influence over the masses to
drag him down mentally it's also like
even if you came out of the blip
immediately if Daredevil came
immediately out of the blip he would be
the same you know you can't just go back
to living you see that in Falcon and the
Winter Soldier the people became manic
after returning with Justin Benson and
Aaron Morehead becoming the new
directors for born again they both have
Marvel experience working on moonight
and with Loki season 2 though I'm proud
of Loki in the end like he wasn't really
given a choice and neither was moonight
when revealed to be still working under
konu so I think we can expect the same
sort of outcome because these directors
are great at not letting our hero win so
I expect Daredevil to be portrayed as
the villain by born again but also
privately suffering from his own battles
that that will unfortunately come out
unfavorable and probably very violent to
the public making him out to be the
villain he's always vowed to fight while
Daredevil's character is being tested
Kingpin is probably escaping from jail
during the blip and returning to his old
school crime ways in an interview with
Screen Rant in regards to how the blip
affected his operations Vincent denafo
said Kingpin had lost some of his power
and he needed to get his City back we
see that actually happening during the
fight in Ekko where his goons mentioned
that people are moving in on fisk's
territories and they were sent out there
to take them out as they said in the
same Screen Rant article I'm sure his
employees in the city were massively
affected by the blip so like Ekko he
gave them work and purpose promising
Futures and homes as New York began to
diminish using that great tactic of his
gaslighting people into working for him
I'm going to punch him in that big old
head he's also influencing people while
they're already under traumatic stress
from watching half the population
disappear and yes I know I'm not a
doctor that's the other Jessica Clemens
but I imagine in a post blip World Fisk
to Daredevil is like Bane to Batman you
merely adopted the dark I was born it
you think after the events of Ekko
Kingpin might have lightened up maybe he
wants to make a New Journey and use that
same control and love he used Amaya to
love bomb the city of New York well in
an interview with Vincent denafo and The
Hollywood Reporter he said Maya's powers
in the finale didn't change him just
inlined him and now he's running for May
he's the same old Fisk and just on a
power hungry mission to have it all at
the end of Ekko he said we need to
stabilize the situation what if the
situation was Daredevil and he knew Maya
was the best weapon he had to take him
on like during their very first fight
the news with that light bulb and new
strategy to break Daredevil politically
and legally rather than blowing up half
the city again the mayor Fisk storyline
also isn't new Charles sule's Daredevil
issue showcase mayor Fisk winning using
his charm rigging the election and
having New York on a string he runs his
campaign on an anti-vigilante agenda and
sends his cops after Daredevil
throughout the series and we know
Daredevil isn't going to take out honest
people so it's a perfect Ambush
Daredevil makes it his mission to
Dethrone King Pin and eventually he does
with the help of the other Defenders
though the storyline is sort of proving
itself in the MCU in the com comcs in
that run kingping doesn't know that Matt
is Daredevil he works as the deputy
mayor but in our MCU he knows that face
so I don't think everything will be
adapted but reminding us of the legal
representation that comes with being a
mayor and maybe him forcing Matt to
represent him regardless and having
access to all the city's resource is an
important and a major takeaway from the
comic books at one point they had like a
static reverberation thing that messed
up Matt's hean and it drove him crazy
essentially I'm sure he'll do what the
sovia Accords did and put the fear and
Vigilantes and superheroes into the eyes
of civilian as he did in the comics but
if we wanted to step away from the sovia
Accords agenda likee mandate we could
simply remember Falcon and the Winter
Soldier and how after the blip everyone
helped those returning and basically
discarded those who survived ke ping
could blame the heroes for not being
there for the city post blip or blame
the heroes for their disappearance and
having a horrible decline in the economy
there are a million ways to persuade the
public especially in the MCU Matt will
not only be framed as the bad guy but in
our eyes we'll become a villain for a
moment Ekko was a bad guy and then an
anti-hero now look at get her between
the new directors and the dark tones of
the Netflix's MCU coming over and Rising
I think we expect small to no wins in
Daredevil in the first season as we
normally do and what keeps us coming
back for the next season we don't want
to see our boy fall but this is born
again he'll bounce back his villain Arc
will begin in the blip and torture him
inside and hopefully with the help of
the Defenders will bring him out of that
Darkness that's my theory and that's
just my idea follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at Lulu Clemens full new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
check out the break room and the Deep
dive let's all hope that we can become
baddies one day without the abusive
manipulative psychological dark tones I
come with it God what happened to
villains just blowing up the moons and
giggling
[Music]
bye